ma question s'appelle s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre la République a toujours besoin
de savants elle doit donc commencer par
favoriser les pépinières scientifiques
la réforme du lycée a été bâclée avec
comme seul objectif une économie de
moyens deux ans plus tard le bilan que
nous pouvons adresser est bien
inquiétant oui l'heure est grave
monsieur le ministre c'est toute une
filière qui est en train de couler nous
ne formons plus à cette scientifiques
alors même que la France a fait le choix
de réinvestir massivement dans la
recherche publique et l'innovation en
deux ans entre 2019 et 2021 le nombre
d'élèves scientifiques en terminale a
diminué de 24%. les élèves bénéficiant
d'un enseignement renforcé en
mathématiques sont de moins en moins
nombreux la part des jeunes filles dans
l'ensemble des parcours scientifiques
est aussi en chute libre 20 ans
d'efforts pour les amener à s'engager
dans des formations exigeantes autrefois
largement réservées aux garçons ont été
balayés d'un trait de plumes
les mathématiques la physique la chimie
le numérique les sciences informatiques
les sciences de l'ingénieur ont tout
disparu du tronc commun et sont
aujourd'hui relégués au rang
d'enseignement de spécialités ou
d'enseignement optionnels en Première et
en terminale les mesures annoncées à la
hâte à la fin de l'année scolaire
2021-2022 ne sont qu'un écran de fumée
vous ne pouvez pas décemment former un
ingénieur en lui enseignant 1h30 de
mathématiques dans le tronc commun en
première et trois heures d'option
mathématiques complémentaires pour tous
en terminale c'est toute la structure du
style terminal qu'il faut revoir sans
délai si nous voulons répondre à
l'exigence scientifique des formations
du supérieur et produire les compétences
dont dépend notre et nos coéconomie ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
elle dictée par l'urgence allez-vous
suspendre cette réforme et réunir toutes
les parties prenantes afin de réfléchir
à la mise en oeuvre de solutions
efficaces et durables pour renverser ce
déclin dès la rentrée 2023 à défaut je
crois que notre compatriote Hugo du
minil copain qui a reçu en juillet
dernier la médaille field pour ses
travaux en physique statistique et
travail à Bures-sur-Yvette dans mon
département soit le dernier Français à
recevoir cette prestigieuse récompense
je vous remercie de votre réponse
[Applaudissements]